[Music]
physics anyone hi my name is Aneesa
Ramirez welcome to science explained and
welcome to the home of the New Haven
open at Yale today I'd like to talk to
you a little bit about the science of
tennis which is one of my favorite
sports tennis is certainly evolved over
the years
just look at the rackets the rackets
used to be made out of wood and now
they're made out of high-tech composites
wood was the dominant material for about
400 years but it had a lot of issues it
had low strength and it suffered warpage
now we use high-tech composites which
are made out of carbon fibers that are
embedded in epoxy which is just a fancy
word to say glue now these materials
have high strength but they also have
low weight so let's also talk a little
bit about the strengths first what are
they made out of they're made out of
natural gut which is actually the
intestines of a cow one cow can string
three tennis racquets that's a lot of
cow but most people actually don't use
natural gut we use nylon which is a
flexible polymer that's used in a lot of
materials that we take for granted like
backpacks guitar strings and the like so
what exactly do the strings do well
there's one shot that's very important
for the strings the strings hit the top
of the ball and create topspin topspin
is a great shot because it makes the
ball fall down sooner than a ball that
doesn't have topspin you see there's an
effect called the Magnus effect which
says that a rotating ball with topspin
will fall down faster with the thinner
ball without topspin so what's going on
well it ends up but while the ball is
rotating a thin layer of air around it
is also rotating with it so that means
that the velocity of air below it is
faster than the velocity above it this
also means that the pressure below is
lower than the pressure above it causing
the ball to fall down sooner
professionals use a lot of topspin Venus
Williams has top spins on the order of
1,200 revolutions per minute or rpm and
Nadal has a crushing 3,600 revolutions
per minute that's really fast when the
doll hits
it rotates 80 times from one end of the
court to the other end of the court
those rotations are faster than the
rotations in a washing machine that's
really fast and so you see knowing a
little bit about physics can really give
you an advantage in tennis I'm Aneesa
Ramirez thank you for joining us at
science explained and I hope that you'll
join us for another edition